today on the matt walsh show a viral
video reveals again that our once great
american cities have turned into
something out of a horror movie the
question is why and how this happened
i'll give my answer my theory today also
five headlines including good news about
covid and its effect on children that
the cdc and the media is trying to dress
up as bad news of course and the ceo of
a video game developing company uh comes
out as pro-life and then pays the
expected consequences plus joe biden
changes his mind about when life begins
and a female sports reporter claims that
she was groped by fans groped while
reporting on a football game but the
video shows something different we'll
play that today all of that and much
more today on the matt walsh
and one of the most difficult and
frustrating things about being a
conservative in the culture today is
that
all of these companies that you're
giving money to every single day most of
them hate your guts and uh you know they
they want to cancel they want to censor
you for your beliefs but you're still
giving them giving them your money and
that's why it's so important when you
find a company that supports you and
your values to support them
in return and that's what charity mobile
is all about they're the pro-life phone
company uh because five percent of your
monthly plan price goes to a pro family
pro uh pro-life charity of your choice
other mobile service providers are at
best neutral when it comes to family and
life issues
many of them again are diametrically
opposed to you but that's not the case
with charity mobile they're all about
supporting you in the culture they also
have
great great service they're supporting
you with as well they've got 5g phones
which are available they have excellent
coverage with nationwide service
on america's most reliable network new
activation knowledgeable accounts get a
free cell phone with free activation and
free shipping when you mention offer
code walsh so you want to do that right
now switch to charity mobile and support
a company and causes that you care about
call them at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com and mention offer
code walsh
as we have been focused on the trials
and tribulations of afghans over the
past uh several weeks not to mention the
past several decades past couple of
decades at least it might be easy to
lose track of the fact that our own
civilization is falling apart at the
seams
there's a viral video which uh picked up
steam after it was reposted by jack
bosobiac which gives us a startling
glimpse into what our cultural collapse
actually looks like
in fact if you didn't know any better
and you look at this video
you would think that it's from not from
america at all but from some kind of
third world hellhole or else maybe from
a hollywood sound stage where they're
filming another
zombie apocalypse movie but tragically
the zombie infested third world
wasteland that you can see in the video
is called philadelphia trash and debris
littering the streets
homeless laying all over the sidewalk
people wandering around hunched over
in drugged out stupors
it's a vision of horror and desperation
and gloom
now this i believe is kensington avenue
in philadelphia it's the poorest most
violent part of one of the poorest and
most violent cities in america the
violent crime rate around kensington is
328 violent crimes per 10 000 residents
now for comparison's sake the violent
crime rate for the whole nation
is 366 per 100 000.
and people who live in philadelphia and
are familiar with this area they'll tell
you that um
what you can see in the video is uh is
what that area and much of the rest of
the city
looks like all the time
every day 24 7.
this is it
this is an american city
philadelphia
again a one a once a great city
one of our greatest
historically speaking
now philadelphia may be especially bad
but it's not even the worst and even the
cities that are a little better are yet
still horror shows in their own right
but what you see on kensington can be
seen to a degree slightly better or
worse
in every major u.s city in fact in our
travels last week we visited we visited
several major cities
that looked something like this
we're told that our cities have turned
into these dirty horrifying
crime-ridden cesspools because of drugs
and certainly the drug epidemic is one
of the most prominent most immediate
causes
just to give you an idea of the scope
and severity of the drug problem i can
tell you that drug overdose deaths have
quadrupled since 1999
and it's not like the rate was
especially low in 1999 to begin with
over the course of those two decades
nearly one million people
one million have died from overdoses
sadly one of the most recent in that
line is the brilliant actor michael k
williams who portrayed omar on the wire
um about another decaying city baltimore
he was found dead of an apparent heroin
overdose this weekend
and these are just overdose deaths we're
talking about this doesn't this doesn't
account for all the many millions of
lives that have been if not technically
ended by drugs still completely
destroyed by them
and families as well
so why is this happening
i think many answers might be given
some of them political all of these
drugged out slums are run by democrats
that's not a coincidence
but then how did democrats manage to
seize control in the first place
and why do people keep voting for them
in these cities
i mean you could if you're in kensington
you can look around and say it literally
can't be worse i mean this is as bad as
a city can get
why would i keep voting for the people
who made it this way
or at the very least were in charge
while it became this way
now you might also point to the collapse
of the family
which is uh which is a factor yeah but
why did the family collapse
you might approach this from the
economic angle and connect it to
poverty and unemployment yeah but why
are so many people in these cities
unemployed especially when there are at
present there are 10 million jobs
available
so i think all of these
are pieces of the puzzles symptoms of
the underlying disease but they are not
themselves the underlying disease
and then what happens when we use a
wider lens and we consider our decaying
cities within a broader cultural context
how does everything else fit into this
picture what about the
skyrocketing numbers of people who've
grown dependent on legal drugs
prescribed to them by doctors especially
psychiatric drugs
what about the enormously high rates of
depression anxiety what about our
experiences with covet all of these
millions of people in america and across
western civilization who have been eager
to give up their liberty for the tenuous
promise of safety
people who even after being vaccinated
still won't leave the house without a
mask speaking of my own experience in
the cities over the past week and um
and over the past year i'm not sure if
i'm more depressed by the sight of the
homeless encampments
or the wealthy people in designer
clothing walking down the street outside
with masks on
and you know every single one of them
are vaccinated
so why is all that happening is that
another piece of the puzzle
and then what about the identity crisis
gripping our culture especially among
kids we've forgotten what the words man
and woman mean we look for for meaning
in these new and increasingly bizarre
redundant and contrived
gender labels
meanwhile we again especially kids spend
most of our days staring at screens
consuming up to 10 hours of media a day
or more
the list of woes goes on and on and
there's probably no reason to keep
listing them
but it's important to look at all these
problems all together because i would
suggest
that underneath all of this
there is a common root system
and the root system is despair
we are gripped in our society by a
crisis an epidemic of despair
we speaking in general terms we've lost
our sense of meaning and purpose which
is what it means to be in despair
when you have no collective sense of
meaning or purpose then your whole
civilization becomes like one of those
druggies on kensington just ambling
around hunched over
moaning and babbling to itself
nowhere to go nothing to do no sense
that there's any real
reason to exist in the first place now
it wasn't always like this in western
civilization we weren't perfect in the
past to put up mildly we had our
flaws there were very deep flaws as any
human civilization has flaws
because it is a civilization of humans
after all not of angels
but we were rooted in a common
understanding and recognition of god's
providence
in our society
we believed
that we were children of god sent here
to do his will
now we may have fallen short of that
calling but we recognized the calling
and that calling gave us as a
civilization a purpose a point a
direction
but then over a period of years and
through a process that we don't have
time to document right now
god was removed from the picture
now not actually removed of course
because you can't
remove him really but we declared all
the same in nietzsche's phrase that god
is dead and that we no longer need him
that we can make our own meaning
but even nietzsche recognized that if
you're going to kill god
kick him off the throne
then you become god and with that title
you inherent inherit an awful lot of
responsibility
whereas god gave us purpose and meaning
before
now if you're taking god out of the
equation
now you need to make your own purpose
and meaning
you will need to replace that god-sized
hole with something
but we never really bothered to figure
that part of it out
we kind of staged this mutiny and killed
the captain while we're out at sea but
nobody else on board knew how to
navigate
we said no no the captain is taking us
in the wrong direction we don't want to
go in that direction
so we took control of the ship and
instead of going in that direction
we went nowhere
we are now a society at drift
and it's up to each person to fill the
hole with something some people choose
drugs
some people choose to waste their lives
playing video games watching netflix
some look for meaning in their gender
identity or their critical theories of
race
everybody is
grasping at the air staggering around in
circles going nowhere
now you can't escape what i'm saying
here by simply
saying that you don't believe in god i
mean you could listen to this and say
well i don't believe in god so i don't
think that it is a problem
see the thing is whatever you believe
there's no question that western
civilization
once did believe
in god and now for the most part it does
not
there's also no question that the belief
gave a sense of purpose
there's also no question that when you
remove the purpose from a person or a
group
and you don't replace it with any kind
of new purpose
then you will have ushered in despair
and hopelessness without offering any
remedy for it
100 years into this process and still
none of the people who've worked to
remove god from the center of our
cultural life have come up with anything
to put into that place
that's the story of modern leftism
destroy but don't rebuild
erase definitions
don't offer new definitions
shout no we don't want to go that way
without saying where else we should go
and this
is where we've ended up
as a result
now let's get to our five headlines
one thing we've talked about quite a bit
on this show is the uh the struggle that
business owners have been going through
to
hire to find people to hire um it's a
real problem and that's why if you're a
business owner if you're an employer you
got to take advantage of great tools
when they're available to you like zip
recruiter the lockdowns of the last year
and a half created a pent-up demand for
places like gyms nail salons hotels all
of them on an epic hiring spree to
accommodate the surge of business so
where do these businesses turn to fill
these roles fast they turn to zip
recruiter and right now you can try it
for free at ziprecruiter.com walsh when
you post a job on zip recruiter they
send your job to over 100 top job sites
and they give you access to their
network of millions of job seekers you
can easily review recommended candidates
and invite your top choices to apply for
your job so this is an active thing
you're doing you're not just putting a
listing out there and hoping someone
stumbles across it the zip recruiter is
going to go out and they're going to
find the right employee for your job and
right now you could try zip recruiter
for free at this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com
walsh that's ziprecruiter.com walsh just
go to ziprecruiter.com
walsh w-a-l-s-h zip recruiter the
smartest way to hire
all right so uh
real quickly amazon prime tweeted out a
question that i thought was a a very
important question
what movie
do you want to see the all-female reboot
of that was a question they put out on
twitter
what movie do you want to see the
all-female reboot of
now i thought about this and really my
problem with the all-female reboot is
that it's not nearly progressive enough
so what i would like to see is a reboot
of goodfellas starring a cast of
transgender pansexuals of color
and the new title should be good dems
that's what i want to see
and i would actually watch that
unironically
if you're going to do the if you're
going to do the woke reboot then really
go for it i mean really embrace it
though of course in truth the real
answer to that question aside from uh
good themes
is uh is none uh you know i like
everyone else in the movie going public
have zero interest in any female reboots
of any kind
like nobody actually wants to see them
but hollywood will keep churning them
out anyway
uh speaking of things that nobody wants
to um really see quick political news
from california's recall election
caitlyn jenner is polling at one percent
now larry elder
is is doing well far and away among the
republican challengers
far and away is is the uh i mean he is
the the challenger all the other
republicans are
far far behind
caitlyn jenner though polling at one
percent
i mean who who could have predicted this
besides the guy sitting at this desk
right here
it's almost like i i s you know i hate
to say i told you so i don't really hate
to say it in fact i love saying it i'll
say it again here i told you so
this um this plan now this this and i
hope you'll you'll remember not that we
want to hold grudges
but keep in mind
when caitlyn jenner first announced his
candidacy uh for for the governorship in
california remember the conservatives
who filed in line behind it
and said this is brilliant this is great
this is like the best of both worlds
we have we have our very own transgender
person
our very own transgender look at this
the left won't know what to do
and it's in california and and and
and
it will attract
people on the left and people on the
right
and there were some of us like myself
who said nah it's not going to happen
see when you try to play the left's game
as a republican
all you end up doing is alienating your
own people
so caitlyn jenner
is not only a transgender individual but
also as someone who not surprisingly
is an advocate for a vocal advocate for
trans ideology for gender ideology so
it's going to alienate almost everybody
on the right
is it going to attract people from the
left no
because it's still as far as they're
concerned
even though
what caitlyn jenner was was advocating
in his positions
especially on the gender stuff is far
left
far left
but as far as the left's concerned they
don't they don't need to settle for some
republican
they they get the real deal
so you're not going to attract them
you're not going to attract very many
people on the right and then you end up
with with this
um
and it's this is not just about spiking
the football it's partly that but it's
also again remember the conservatives
with with all with audiences with
platforms
who told you that caitlyn jenner
candidacy was a great idea
remember them remember their judgment
the next time they come around and say
here's a great candidate
yeah this is the person who thought
caitlyn jenner would do well
in california
speaking of california also uh politics
um gavin newsom
was
and you could tell that that
larry elder is the guy because gavin
newsom
i don't know if he's said anything about
caitlyn jenner at all but he's he's not
getting up
in front of audiences and blasting away
at caitlyn jenner he's not worried about
caitlyn jenner he is worried about larry
elder so here he is attacking larry
elder a couple days ago and also
coming forward with some this is pure
this is like pandering on steroids but
let's listen to this
the idea
that we have someone on the other side
of this ballot that could be sworn in in
a matter of weeks
that not only doesn't believe a woman
has the right to choose
not only doesn't believe the center said
women are as smart as men
by the way i don't know
if you've seen senator warren
cross-examine folks on wall street
apparently larry elder has not
women are smarter in politics smarter in
civics they're smarter in economics
women rule
man
i really thought i really thought he was
going to literally shout girl power i
thought that's what was coming at the
end of that
they're smarter they're better
we are but scum in comparison with them
how many women uh
actually find that kind of pandering
appealing
maybe
on the left maybe maybe it plays i don't
know but i would like to think that even
women on the left
hear that and and
and take it for the infantilizing
nonsense that it actually is
treating women like
like children here's a goal you're
awesome you're the best you're special
here's a gold star
i i would i know on on the right
certainly women
have no time for that but uh on the left
i would i would like to believe that
even on the left
aside from the trained seals in the
audience they're clapping
most other women women would hear that
it's that come on
especially because i had to look this up
while he was babbling there
who is the lieutenant governor of
california
well the lieutenant governor is a woman
um
eleni kunalakis i'm probably
mispronouncing the name but it doesn't
matter lieutenant governor is a woman
and it's without fail when you hear this
kind of thing
joe biden has said similar stuff
but almost without fail when you hear
this from a politician
and you look at their second in command
it it's a woman so if you really feel
that way if you actually think women are
better women women are more equipped to
lead so
then why aren't you stepping down and
letting a woman why don't you resign and
let the
lieutenant governor step in
if you really believe that
uh and by the way i have no doubt let me
just say
this that i i have no doubt that
almost every woman in the country is
smarter and better than gavin newsom so
that i you know so this is a speak for
yourself situation
that i uh i have no doubt at all
all right here's a story that i wish i
could say had a twist ending but it
doesn't it ends exactly as you would
expect it begins with the this is maybe
the unexpected part the ceo of a company
called tripwire which is a video game
developer software developer
uh the ceo john gibson
in reaction to the texas abortion ban
tweeted this a couple of days ago
and he said saying that he was quote
proud of the u.s supreme court affirming
the texas law banning abortion for
babies with a heartbeat
as an entertainer i don't get political
often yet with so many vocal peers on
the other side of the issue i felt it
was important to go on the record as a
pro-life game developer
and so that was it that was all he said
and you know i saw that a couple days
ago when he first tweeted it and i
thought well very well done takes a lot
of guts to
come out in your position and say that
but
[Music]
there goes your job your job is gone and
that's exactly what happened reading now
from ign it says following his comments
supporting the texas anti-abortion law
tripwire ceo john gibson has stepped
down from the company
um behind such games as man eater and
chivalry 2.
those are video games i guess okay
tripwire announced the news alongside
confirming that co-founding member and
current vice president alan wilson will
now act as interim ceo in its statement
tripwire shared that gibson's views do
not reflect the company as a whole
and that his comments disregarded the
values of our whole team our partners
and much of our broader community
he said quote the comments given by john
gibson are of his own opinion and do not
reflect those of tripwire interactive as
a company his comments disregarded the
values of our whole team our partners
and much of our broader community our
leadership team at tripwire are deeply
sorry and are unified in our commitment
to take swift action and to foster a
more positive environment they're deeply
sorry
that
this one guy john gibson has an opinion
that
some
fans of the video games this company
develops you know disagree with
effective immediately john gibson has
stepped down as ceo of tripwire
interactive and uh alan wilson is
stepping in
uh allen will work with the rest of the
tripwire leadership team to take steps
with employees and partners to address
their concerns including executing a
company-wide town hall meeting and
promoting open dialogue with tripwire
leadership and all employees so this is
a
they're treating this as a five-alarm
fire
this one guy who's yeah the ceo of the
company
you would think that would
offer him some protection but it doesn't
says that just voices his own opinion
that's it
here's my opinion on pro-life
an opinion shared by tens of millions of
people across the country
and
take his job they're gonna have town
hall meetings they're gonna they're
gonna be talking to the employees that
were traumatized by this
and there's an important lesson to be
taken from this
a lesson that if you haven't already
learned this
here it is again
uh if you are a conservative
you are not welcome
in mainstream society and it's as simple
as that
no matter what your views are
because john gibson his his views again
these are these are
common views there was there was nothing
extreme here
all he said was yeah i like the law i'm
pro-life
um
not welcome at all
you know on the left
if if
there's a chorus of from the perspective
of a leftist if there's a chorus of a
hundred thousand people agreeing with
them
and repeating their opinions back to
them
you know that doesn't matter if there's
even one person in that core of the 100
000 people surrounding them saying i
agree with everything you think i'll
repeat your opinions back here if
there's one guy in that crowd
saying something different or even just
not saying anything at all not actively
affirming
then it's a crisis
and that individual leftist is now being
attacked by that one person
who's not agreeing with them while
everybody else is
and this is important thing to realize
because
we as conservatives need to let go of
the delusion
that we can live according to our
principles and
still get along well with everybody
and kind of keep these aspects of our
lives separate because we can't
you know you can you you're a
conservative over here and these are
your principles this is what you believe
deeply inside your soul
and then this is the rest of your life
and just can't keep those in two nice
little containers
we don't need to combine them at all
that's not gonna work
because the left is they're they're
hunting down
anyone if you have that container even
if you're not even if you're trying to
keep it separate from the rest of your
life and go about your days
putting your principles
aside the left's on a mission to find
you and smoke you out
it's a decision we have to make we
there's a decision and john gibson made
his decision i think it was a truly
courageous decision
and he's not a stupid guy he knew what
he was doing
he knew there's a very good chance he
could lose his job
and yet he chose to stand up anyway
that is
truly courageous
as as often as that word is misused this
is a correct usage of the term
so there's a decision that we make um
are we going to
take that separate little container
that's got our values and everything
that we hold deeply
within ourselves are we just going to
toss it out and say forget this
assimilate ourselves into the larger
culture
can't beat them might as well join them
type of thing
or are we going to say you know forget
about the separate containers this is
who i am this is what i believe
and i'm going to live according to it
i think that's the decision we have to
make
um and all of us as conservatives we
have to make that decision first
before we can do anything else
before we decide what the next move is
what the next step is
all right um meanwhile a guest on msnbc
has as we just continue to talk about
the texas abortion ban a guest
msnbc had a suggestion for how to deal
with the texas law there's been various
different
uh suggestions here
the common thread
um is that
texas cannot be allowed to have their
own laws forget about states rights
doesn't matter
we can't allow them to do this and there
have been different suggestions here's a
guy
with a particular particularly dire
i think approach to this let's listen
as horrible as this texas law is this
year 2021 has already seen more abortion
restrictions proposed and passed than
any other year in united states history
what changed between 2020 and 2021 oh i
remember ruth bader ginsburg died and
amy coney barrett got on the court so we
we knew this was coming the states knew
it was coming the republicans knew it
was coming and for us just now to be
like oh maybe now we need a whole of
government response yeah yeah you think
like that should have already been in
place we should have known that this was
coming look i live in new york okay it
is wet right now if i was on top of my
roof
kind of looking for help i would expect
the cavalry to be coming directly right
fema coast guard operation dumbo drop
somebody should be coming to get me
and in fact when it happened in katrina
and katrina the failure of the federal
government to go get people was viewed
as one of the biggest failures of that
of george w bush's presidency similarly
we need to go and get women in texas and
protect their constitutionally protected
medical rights and the way you do that
is that you deputize doctors you
federalize doctors you create through an
executive order an army
an army so what he's talking about there
and he goes on uh ranting and raving
i mean this is someone he says himself
he lives in new york
and uh
he he lives in new york and the idea
that that women will not be able to kill
their children in texas the idea that
more babies will be allowed to live he
takes he is personally insulted by that
this is an emergency for him we have to
figure out a way to kill those babies
that's what he's saying
and his solution is
let's federalize a literal army of
doctors
to go into texas and start killing
babies
to make sure those babies are not
allowed to be born
this is a this is emergency there's
urgency to it
now he's saying there are thousands of
unborn babies right now if we don't kill
them right now they'll be born and then
they'll share the planet with me i don't
want to share the planet with those
damn disgusting babies
that's his attitude
it's hard to even wrap your mind around
if you're a normal
mostly morally adjusted person
a person with some basic human decency
within yourself
it's hard to
you almost don't want to believe
that there could be people who like hate
babies this much and want to kill them
and are horrified and disgusted by the
thought that more babies will exist
but that's that's the case here
it goes back to what we talked about at
the very beginning
people who have removed god from their
lives completely
all sense of uh objective morality and
objective moral worth of human beings
they've taken that out
and these are people are just collapsing
into themselves totally empty inside
and they're their moral depravity just
knows no bounds whatsoever
that's also the case for stella parton
she's the obscure lesser-known sister of
dolly parton she tweeted this she says
don't you find it odd that women in
america are being treated worse than
women in afghanistan
we wasted two trillion dollars plus to
go into afghanistan to liberate their
women and children something ain't right
here folks are you catching on yet
she's certainly not the only feminist to
say that
not even like it's equal but
if you're a woman especially in texas
you're not allowed to kill your baby
then you are you have it worse than a
woman in afghanistan
a woman who can't show her face in
public without being stoned to death
i'm not going to bother
explaining why that's crazy because if
you need to have it explained to you
then there's nothing i can say in
explaining it
that will be able to penetrate through
your
insanity to make sense to you so instead
i'll say this and i and i mean this
sincerely this is this is a real offer
to stella pardon or any other feminist
who feels this way
that you know you have it worse than any
other women on earth
it's better in afghanistan well this is
what i'll say to you i will personally
pay
to send you to afghanistan
into the
welcoming arms of the taliban
i will pay if you really think it's
better there
and you don't want to be here anymore
and you're thinking grass is greener on
the other
side well they don't have a lot of grass
over there but the sand is
browner on the other side of the fence
or something um then i will pay
to send you there
we'll have to figure out the logistics a
little bit
you know there aren't a lot of flights i
don't think you could like catch a delta
flight into afghanistan right now but
we'll figure out a way
maybe this should be the next
fundraising campaign
since we couldn't get the money to uh to
aoc zaboyla maybe we start a fundraising
campaign to send women who feel like
it's better in afghanistan to you know
send them there and uh
that's a win-win for everybody really i
would think
um
also bette midler had this she said i
suggest that all women refuse to have
sex with men until they're guaranteed
the right to choose by congress
but a lot of this kind of reaction to
and this is kind of interesting because
for one thing it it
you're acknowledging
um the possibility
of abstinence
because what you're saying here is well
you know women especially in texas
if they don't if they don't want to have
a baby
and they can't tolerate the idea of
getting pregnant
at all
then they then then maybe they should
just not have sex they should they
should abstain well uh yeah
well now you're understanding bette
midler exactly right
if you ca if the idea of having a baby
if you're in a position
where it's not just like
you don't want to be a parent right now
specifically but just you you can't even
tolerate the notion of it
okay if you're in a position where or
you're the sort of person who
would rather kill
than have a baby
then yes you should not be having sex
you are you are not the kind of person
who should be having any sexual
relations with anybody
you're not you're not in the right place
for it you're not competent enough for
it
um you are
an emotionally stunted person
that you would choose murder over having
a baby so all of these things factored
together what i would say is yeah i
agree with bette midler just probably
abstinence is the way to go
of course she means that as a threat to
men
or she's saying well all the
pro-abortion women
we're not going to have sex with men
anymore that i got to tell you that's i
i hear that as more of a promise than a
threat
i think most men hear that and think
dodged a bullet there
and i really mean that because um and
and don't take the offense to this but
but pro-abortion women
to my mind
are uh repulsive
i find them repulsive in every sense of
the word
i mean these are these are women who
have
rejected
all of the feminine and maternal parts
of themselves
um and i you know i think i think most
men find that naturally repulsive
we want women who are caregivers
women who care for children
loving women
[Music]
you know those are the kinds of women
that men find appealing and um that's
not the case for pro-abortion women so
this is another kind of win-win
situation i would say
all right one other thing here on the
the abortion issue joe biden a couple
days ago
talking about when life begins
uh he said that uh you know he
acknowledges that some people think that
life begins at conception but he doesn't
agree with that
and that's sort of interesting
considering something you said a few
years ago but let's play this clip first
i have been continue to be
a strong supporter of roe v wade
number one
and uh
the most pernicious thing about the
texas law
it sort of creates a vigilante system
where people get rewards to go out
anyway
and it just seems i know this sounds
ridiculous almost un-american
what we're talking about
not to debate about i under i respect
people who think
that who don't support roe v wade i
respect their views
i respect them those who believe life
begins in the moment of conception and
all i i respect that don't agree but i
respect that i'm not going to impose
that on people
but what i was told and i must tell you
i am not certain
i was told that there are possibilities
within the existing law
to have the justice department look and
see whether are there things that can be
done
that can limit
the
independent action of individuals and
enforcing a federal system
a state law
i don't know enough to give you an
answer yet i've asked that to be checked
okay so he uh respects he allegedly
respects people
who don't support roe v wade
and yet
you know if if
the people of texas vote in a government
that is pro-life and they want to have
pro-life laws joe biden wants to stop
that from happening that's how much he
respects pro-life people
he also wants to force you to fund the
abortion industry
which we all do 500 to the tune of 500
million dollars a year funding planned
parenthood that's how much he respects
your views
i respect your views he's saying but
i don't think you should be allowed to
legislate according to those views or
elect people who will legislate
according to those views and also i want
to force you to i want to take your
money and uh and force you to fund the
abortion history that's how much i
respect your views
great
but he says he doesn't agree he doesn't
think the life begins at conception
and that's interesting because only
about five years ago he was singing a
very different tune let's watch
i'm prepared to accept a feed a doctrine
on a whole range of issues as a catholic
um
even though as you know
aquinas argued about
ensuemotheologic about human life and
being when it occurs i'm prepared to
accept as a matter of faith
my wife and i my family the issue of of
of abortion
but what i'm not prepared to do is
impose a rigid view
precise view
rigid sounds
pejorative a precise view
that is born out of my faith
on other people who are equally
god-fearing
equally as committed to life equally as
committed to
uh the sanctity of life and uh
i'm prepared to accept that the moment
of conception of human life and being
but i'm not i'm not prepared to say that
to
other god-fearing non-god-free people
that have a different view
so many problems there before we get to
the main problem the main contradiction
but
the claim that pro-abortion christians
are equally as god-fearing and equally
as committed to the sanctity of life
well that doesn't make any sense to
begin with because pro-abortion
christians is a non-existent category
you can't really be a pro-abortion
christian you especially cannot be a
pro-abortion catholic
you can't
he's not a catholic
and i can say that
because
to be a catholic means
to begin with at a minimum
accepting the moral authority of the
church if you don't and you don't have
to accept the moral authority of the
church
no one is forced to legally in this
country
but if you don't then you're not a
catholic
i mean there's a lot of other things you
can be but you're not a catholic
but aside from all that he says that
he's he's prepared to accept
that life begins at conception
he was prepared to accept it
five six years ago apparently he's not
prepared anymore
and and even even five six years ago he
said i don't want to impose
that a precise view on people
yet he is willing to impose the belief
that life does not begin at conception
on people
by again forcing them to fund the
abortion industry
and other ways as well
so this is this is someone who
as we know about joe biden
this is the defining characteristic of
him and it's not only be it's it's not
just now that he has dementia and he's
confused and he you know he contradicts
himself all the time dementia has
certainly not made it any better but
he's always been this way a man
with with no
principles at all
and a totally empty hollowed-out person
who will say whatever he needs to say in
the moment
and that's it
like so many other politicians but joe
biden
is obviously no exception to that and
yet if i were to take him
you know his most recent statement on
the
when life begins
his real answer to that by the way is i
don't care
that's his real answer
and that's why he said different things
on the subject because he does he
doesn't think about it he doesn't care
makes no difference to him
but
if i was prepared to accept
what his most recent statement and to
believe that it's what he really what he
really believes
which is that life does not begin at
conception
or he doesn't he doesn't think that it
does
well even then
you know
that still would not be an argument for
for abortion
because what you can't you know you you
cannot say
that life definitively does not begin at
conception
because you'll notice the people who say
that life doesn't get a conception
they don't point they're not willing to
point to any other
time in the uh baby's development and
say well that's when life begins
except at birth
and they don't even say it then because
they know that doesn't make any they
know they can't claim that life begins
at birth
that the baby a second before being born
isn't alive they know they can't say
that it doesn't make any sense
so they won't exactly say that most of
the time
they'll say no i don't think it begins
at conception
well when does it begin they won't they
certainly don't want heartbeat they're
not going to accept that
they just want it to be one here's what
they want they want it to be one big
gray area well who knows
so
if it is let's say it is a gray area
which i don't think it is
you know i think life is a particular
thing it has to begin at some
and it only makes logical sense to say
that you began to live at the moment
when you came into existence as a
distinct and separate being
that's it that's the only thing that
makes any logical sense as well
scientific sense
but even if i were to agree that this
that it's a gray area
that wouldn't justify abortion at all
because then what you're saying is
well
it's possible i mean there's a very real
possibility
that the um the quote-unquote fetuses
we're killing are alive that they're
they're living persons but let's kill
them anyway
and that is not a morally justifiable
position
you know what that's like that's like
firing a gun into a dark room
yeah well you don't know if there's
anybody in there
you have no idea you just open the door
dark room you don't know if there's
anybody in there and if there is anyone
in there you don't know where they are
and you just
fire fire shot into the room
i ask you if you were to do that
and yeah you don't know maybe you might
even think that well there's nobody in
the room
there could be but i don't think so
if you were to do that and you shot and
killed someone
should you be held morally responsible
for that
well yeah of course
because you knew there was a very real
possibility that there was a person in
that room and you fired the gun anyway
so the
the the the furthest that the
pro-abortion
position on when life begins can take us
is is all it can do rather than giving
us a definitive date for when life
begins it's just the gray area
which means even according to their own
logic
the babies that are being killed in
abortion
could very well
be living persons that you're killing
anyway
if you're looking at at something a
a being an entity
and you're not sure if it's a living
person or not but it could be
then i think the best thing is to not
kill it
that would be my position
all right moving on now to reading the
youtube comments we didn't have a show
on friday so instead i'm gonna read some
of the comments from
um our very exciting video which we
posted on uh monday the sweet baby gang
anthem contest
and uh
that that went up and i yeah i thought
it was a great experience if you haven't
watched it yeah go to youtube
and check out the sweet baby gang anthem
all the different uh there were five
contestants i thought they were all
tremendous
and we're gonna announce the winner here
soon but let me read some of the
comments from that because we didn't
have a show so even if we did have a
show these are the comments i would be
reading because it's much more important
than the show samantha says you could
feel ben's discomfort whenever michael
called matt daddy
well
that is that is my title and
frankly i was a little bit upset that um
that no one else has agreed to call me
daddy i mean that's i'm sweet daddy
walsh that's my official title
that's what i identify as i expect it to
be respected sam says i love how uh how
much michael's enjoying this and how
much andrew looks like he loads
being there
i enjoyed i really enjoyed that too
um
z zevon says love how they made this as
cheesy and cringy as possible
intentionally and somehow knowles
managed to keep a straight face the
whole time i feel like the producers of
daily wire are wild
cheesy and
cringy
you thought the sweet baby gang contest
was cheesy and cringy
that sacred and solemn undertaking to
decide on the sweet baby king anthem you
saw that and thought oh this is cheesy
and cringy
well you sir are banned from the show
and evicted from the sweet baby gang
eric says that was by far the best thing
that daily wire has ever produced
though ben and drew could have been more
respectful to sweet daddy walsh this was
historic uh game show host does fit
knowles perfectly
i agree with you i think it was i think
um
i don't overstep my bounds you know
and i haven't been at the daily wire
since its inception but
i think that this was our towering
achievement as a company we could close
the doors today
and we will have done everything that we
needed to do i believe
um kayla says i'm so impressed by all
these finalists i can't even be mad i
wasn't a violent finalist when compared
to this talent
matt should really be honored and
impressed by all of the effort of his
sweet baby gang i was i was very honored
by it
and that's why if you watched the video
you know that i came to your defense
the sweet babies as you were being
ruthlessly and viciously attacked
by both drew and ben i i was there and i
defended i will always defend my sweet
babies
and finally i've never seen walsh smile
so much and it's great he's finally is
getting the recognition he deserves and
starting a cult
you know what i think you're right about
that i was i i read that comment and i
thought well this isn't a cult what are
you talking about
and i almost banned you from the show
and evicted you from the sweet baby gang
but then i realized i i think you're
right
i think it is kind of a call and i i i i
am ready now this is my next career move
because it is a question my wife has
even asked me many times
what the hell is this
why are you doing this this is creepy
what's the point
and i haven't really been able to
explain it
except to tell her that she's not
welcome in the sweet baby gang if that's
how she feels about it
but i think this is what this is what
i'll explain to her you know what i
really i'm at the point in my career
where i'm ready to start a cult and um
and become a cult leader and that's what
this is that's that's what this will
turn into so that's pretty exciting
you know the great organization 40 days
for life pro-life organization they've
been uh they have been working for years
and decades and had tremendous success
in converting hearts and minds to the
pro-life cause but they just came out
with a book that there couldn't be a
better time for it given everything
happening right now in the country and
in texas especially the book is what to
say when the complete new guide to
discussing abortion this book is an easy
read for individuals looking to defend
life and convert hearts you know you
encounter all these arguments and
sometimes there are so many like rapid
fire that pro-abortion people can throw
at you all these different arguments and
you know the arguments are bad
but um it can be hard to figure out how
to sift through it and what to respond
and what to say and that's what this
book is all about a lot has changed
since abortion was legalized in 1973
what's to say when equips readers with
proven approaches to dismantling the
pro-abortion agenda these methods have
already enabled 40 days 40 days for life
members to convert the hearts of 221
abortion workers so you know it works so
you got to pick up this book what to say
when the complete new guide to
discussing abortion get free shipping
and 21 off a signed hardback at
40daysforlife.com
what to say when
also you know it's never been more
important to understand what's going on
in the political sphere and that's why
we started our new podcast morning wire
the daily morning show is dedicated to
bringing you all the news you need to
know without any spit spin or hidden
agenda it's the only daily podcast that
values your time and the truth and while
we're working overtime to make sure that
we get this news to you we need your
help to make sure that more people get
access to morning wire and find out
about it so subscribe today and listen
now and also leave that five star review
if you like what you hear now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today i'm very excited actually to
cancel a woman by the name of lindsey go
uh this i believe is one of the most
highly deserved cancellations we've done
in several weeks so of course they're
all highly deserved our friend lindsay
is a sports reporter and also the sports
director over at wtoc in georgia now to
be a sports reporter in georgia
you have to know and love college
football because your audience knows and
loves college football and part of
loving college football is loving the
atmosphere the experience
now it's not for everybody certainly the
game of football is fast and violent and
intense and
sometimes brutal the experience of
watching the game live in the stadium
especially a college stadium is loud and
rowdy and soaked in beer with people
screaming out of anger and out of joy
often switching between the two from
second to second
as a football fan myself this all sounds
like a tremendous amount of fun to me
but as i said it's not for everybody
and i'm afraid it's not for lindsay so
on saturday night um georgia defeated
clemson at home in a hard-fought 10-3
victory
lindsay was reporting at the stadium
and decided to set up for a live shot
right at the exits as 90 000 drunk and
deliriously excited football fans were
filing out she chose to set up her
cameras
in the midst of this swarm
and then was less than pleased with the
results later that night she tweeted
got all kinds of violated during my
first live hit by fans she also claimed
that she'd been groped quote unquote
and she said after that the experience
was uh that she was stressed by the
experience and startled and quote
frazzled
but courageously she assured the public
that she was okay
then the next day as the nation waited
with baited breath for an update from
lindsay who was stressed and frazzled at
the football game
she finally released the footage
now it's up to the eye of the beholder
or the beer holder as the case may be to
decide
whether lindsay was in fact groped and
violated or whether she was simply
greeted with the kind of boozy
enthusiasm that literally anyone
standing in front of a camera in that
situation would have experienced and
that's up to you to decide but uh let's
watch the footage here
hello
we're oh defensive slugfest and the dogs
ran away with it attends
how long how long do i have
please don't touch my equipment please
go
how long do i have i've got to move
okay um i can hear you but i'm moving
okay you know my only problem watching
that is all the people who
uh you know they got their time in the
sun they got their time on camera and
then they kind of froze and they had
nothing to say i mean if you're gonna if
you're gonna intrude into the shot
i respect it because again we're out of
you're at a football game that's what
you do
but you should have something to say a
couple people they kind of stuck their
head into the shot and like didn't they
couldn't think of anything to say so
they just walked away
um now as far as i can tell only one
person made physical contact with her by
touching her on the shoulder
and as i always tell i tell my kids all
the time you got to keep your hands to
yourself it is impolite to touch
somebody on the shoulder like that when
they don't want to be touched
but um does that qualify as groping now
has a person been violated because
another person made non-consensual
contact with their shoulder for 10
seconds or two seconds really
if so then we have all been groped
we have all been groped and violated
thousands of times in our lives
and meanwhile the the stories of women
who have actually been groped and
violated are buried somewhere under this
avalanche of brief benign non-sexual
incidental physical contact between
human beings as for the rest of it
lindsay was encountering what again
anybody
who has set up any kind of camera
outside of any college or professional
sporting event has encountered
the crazy thing is you can see in her
face
from the beginning that she has no
patience for any noise at all
she doesn't appear to want to be there
to begin with
and as soon as people start walking past
she's fuming mad
but but she's the one who set up the
camera exactly where thousands of people
will be walking this is like a guy from
the weather channel reporting live from
the beach during a hurricane and whining
the whole time because his hair is
getting wet
it's like if i tried to make a phone
call while sitting in the stands at a
nascar race like uh hang on a second hey
fellas can you pump the brakes for a
minute and i'm trying to have a
conversation here
of course
that's that's not to say that reporters
can't or shouldn't report live from
stadiums it's just to say that they
should be ready to match the volume
intensity and exuberance of the crowd in
the background
and i certainly don't want to claim
that this is one of the reasons why men
make better sports reporters
i don't want to claim that
so i'm not going to claim that
instead instead i'll just show you an
example of how it's supposed to be done
watch this
well it's been 644 days it's the last
time
did not have restrictions as to how many
fans could be in their stadium but that
ends tonight and while that ends a new
chapter begins as shane beamer begins
his new era as the head football coach
at the university of south carolina
hello everyone and welcome to
the front lots here at the university of
south carolina i'm mike cuba and it is
game day something gamecock fans have
been waiting for for quite some time and
look there's a lot of storylines we
could talk about we could talk about how
shane is making his debut we could talk
about how eric kimbry the former
gamecock quarterback who coached him
these last couple of years is making his
debut as an assistant coach but perhaps
perhaps the biggest storyline
is the fact that you have a former grad
assistant coach seth nolan playing under
center tonight as the starting
quarterback earl in the week we had a
chance to be able to catch up with both
zeb and coach beaver
wow now that was fox reporter mike uva
who in fairness to lindsay mike is
putting on an absolute clinic in that
broadcast that few sports reporters
could fully match
uh and before you say that this was this
this was different because nobody
physically touched him here he is
broadcasting from a bar during march
madness a few years ago here's a better
example watch this
eight seconds
for the first time since 1973 usc is
running to the swift 16.
wow
it is
[Music]
absolutely
[Music]
people are a little bit excited you know
they're they're a little excited covered
in beer people grabbing onto his back
and his shoulders lindsey would be in
counseling for a year after that
experience that's what i want to see
lindsay in that environment she would be
she would break down in tears
she'd be telling stories about the
trauma to her grandchildren 40 years
from now and who knows how the story
would evolve by then
i was trying to do a live shot from the
bar and all these basketball fans with
machetes and chainsaws started hacking
me to pieces
maybe not literally but metaphorically
they were metaphorical chainsaws
now
it wouldn't be fair to say that all
female sports reporters are like lindsay
but even so
i must
say this situation only demonstrates why
i personally prefer for sports
broadcasts especially football
broadcasts to be handled mostly by men
lindsay though worse than the average
even as far as female sports reporters
go
is definitely not the only female to
enter into this mostly male space and
seek to feminize it she wants the
football stadium to be quiet and gentle
considerate respectful of personal space
she wants it to be a more feminine
environment
she's not trying to assimilate herself
into the culture of football fans she is
rather hoping that they assimilate
themselves to her
this is a problem across our culture
sports just happen to be an area where
the problem is especially pronounced and
obvious females enter into areas that
have typically catered and mostly belong
to men
and and then
often quite successfully they try to to
change them to emasculate them and
thereby destroy the primary reason for
their existence in the first place
this phenomenon is so far-reaching in
football especially that they're even
changing the rules now to make the game
itself more gentle and feminine football
is you know still violent
but it's less violent than it used to be
this year they're even focusing on
penalizing players who say mean or rude
things to each other on the football
field they've been doing this during the
preseason in the nfl
all of this
along with the token female sideline
reporters and the female analysts at
halftime it's an effort to make the game
less appealing to the people the game
was invented for to begin with now
meanwhile it should be acknowledged
women are experiencing the same problem
in the reverse
female spaces are being invaded by men
often the most private spaces like
locker rooms for example but but it's a
different kind of invasion not better
it's actually worse but it's different
because
the men invading female spaces
do try to assimilate themselves but they
assimilate themselves too much
they assimilate themselves to the point
of pretending to actually be women and
the effect ultimately is that women
don't just lose their spaces
as men have lost ours they also lose
their identity in the process
so
it's a big confused mess all in all
and it all starts from the incorrect
assumption that there is something wrong
with men and women having their own
spaces their own interests
their own identities
sports reporter lindsay didn't create
this problem
but she is just one more example of it
and for that reason she is today i must
say
cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadosky
the show is edited by sasha thomashove
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by niko geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
21.
texas democrats turn to the satanic
temple to stop a pro-life law california
democrats make students pray to aztec
demons and the establishment media
spread major fake news about kovid check
it out on the michael knowles show